Pour ne loupe aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous et activez le petite cloche.
Salut les Épicurieux !
Connaissez-vous le kaki ?
Ça ressemble à une tomate
mais ça n'a rien à voir.
On peut le déguster entre
le mois d'octobre et le mois de janvier.
Drôle de nom pour un fruit
dont la couleur ne tire jamais sur le kaki
mais plutôt sur le rouge orangé.
Bizarre...
Mais ce n'est rien à côté du nom de
l'arbre sur lequel il pousse : un plaqueminier du Japon !
Et ce n'est pas fini.
cette essence a été domestiquée
non pas au Japon mais en Chine
et son nom, lui, vient d'Amérique, de la côte Est,
d'une région correspondant
grosso modo à la Floride
où pousse une variété locale. Les indiens
algonquins qui y vivaient l'ont baptisé "Piakimina"
qui devint "Plaqueminier"
lorsque l'arbre fut introduit en Europe
à la fin du XVIIIème siècle.
Aujourd'hui en France, il pousse essentiellement
dans le sud du pays, mais on en trouve
également dans la vallée de la Loire.
Goutez-y,
c'est délicieux !
Entre la mangue
et la pêche.
Hmm... c'est bon !
D'ailleurs, son nom scientifique,
qui vient du grec, lui va très bien !
Diospyros, le fruit des dieux. C'est vrai
qu'on pourrait en faire un caprice.
Mais bon... on va pas
en faire un fromage !
SI vous avez aimé cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas
à laisser un pouce bleu. Merci les Epicurieux !
Pour les plus gourmands, en voici d'autres et pour
ne rien rater : abonnez-vous et activez la cloche !